nadia савченко викладу свої уста
слову процесі то співає гімн україни
європейський парламент їм годинник прийшов
вигляд і ви славлю вони продані покаяння до
конкретних ідей
57 євро депутату підписала лист з правильно
не до верховний уявляєте з
випробування сонячними політиками
політики б заспівати і подарувати йому gorenje
тоді пропана вал творить зі списку
савченка за зіницею списку магнітного
парили конкретних перевищив прилюдний
wsus міражах польський євродепутат
я ті ксарі вже польський список
президент Росії Володимир Путін
за ним ідуть директор ФСБ Олександр
бортників голова з особи комітету Росії
Олександр Бастрикін
разом сем і високо по саду всі ми за
голом 29 осі піке за словом і автореф
адже звернення за видаль низових ридання
привіз зайняті незаконну виразками надій
савченко
атаку швабра кати та право євро депутати
допомагають рахунок фігурантом списку зібрані
левісти душі російського союзу забув
кавалера hunky to our втомлювалася їх не
владний над територією з